[Music]
on this Saturday night fears after a
devastating fire in Old Montreal family
and friends of multiple missing people
dread the worst this hope is almost gone
the hurdles for search Crews
surprise trip where the Russian
president visited as he faces an arrest
warrant
fed up and fired up
the growing anger against the Greek
government over this real disaster plus
just call in the pop can man if I was
younger 30 years I'd build a museum a
recycled Museum Making a Splash and
masterpieces one tiny tab at a time
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us a
fatal fire in Old Montreal this week may
be even more devastating than originally
thought police are now taking over the
investigation and believe there are even
more people inside the Heritage building
no one knows for sure because it's still
too dangerous to go inside investigators
say six people are unaccounted for and
as Mike Armstrong reports there could be
even more
it was a gut-wrenching scene friends and
family of some of the missing gathered
in front of the building with their
loved ones were likely lost one of them
a photographer Camille Maier who lived
on the second floor her friends haven't
heard anything from her since the fire
hope is almost gone by now but it's you
just you can't conceive of a thing like
that so you just wait and to confirm
Flames swept through the building
Thursday morning the fire started just
before 6 a.m it was originally built in
1890 for a mining company but had been
converted to 15 apartments and an
architecture office nine people were
taken to hospital two were still being
treated at a burn unit but originally
the fire department said one person was
missing
investigators now say they've been
speaking to families and friends and
believe at least six people are missing
some of the apartments are Airbnb
rentals police are trying to determine
which were occupied and how many people
would have been inside
one of them appears to be 18 year old
Charly Lacroix her father shared the
news on Facebook that she's missing the
family was told she called 9-1-1 during
the fire twice because she couldn't
escape
her grandfather says she was in a room
without Windows was begging for someone
to come and get her
the investigation is being turned over
to the Montreal police arson Squad
because of the loss of life right now
there's nothing to say it was criminally
set in fact investigators haven't even
been in the building yet
ahead of the RC Squad says it's too
dangerous to send anyone inside the roof
of the building collapsed as did parts
of the floors police are working with
the fire department to evaluate the
structure and put together a plan on how
to go in safely
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
despite the ongoing conflict between
Russia and Ukraine the two countries
have agreed on one thing extending a
deal allowing Ukraine to export grain to
developing countries through the Black
Sea The Pact will last at least 60 days
Ukraine hopes even longer and today
marks the ninth anniversary of the day
Russia annexed Crimea to celebrate
Russian President Vladimir Putin made a
surprise trip to the region just one day
after the international criminal court
issued a warrant for his arrest
Mackenzie gray reports
in russian-occupied Crimea the
celebration started early Saturday
morning small groups taking to the
streets to Mark the ninth anniversary of
Crimea being annexed from Ukraine Crimea
has been Russian for centuries says
Sergey from the local biker Club it came
back into Russia's fold and no
celebration would be complete without
the man that made it happen Russian
President Vladimir Putin making a
surprise visit tomb ringer new art
museum to Mark the anniversary
while Putin admired their sculptures
there might have been other things on
his mind late Friday the international
criminal court issued an arrest warrant
for him alleging the Russian president
oversaw the forced deportation of
Ukrainian children
it's an act Moscow was actually
celebrated saying at a rally it had
rescued these Ukrainian kids the other
Mastermind behind the alleged plot has
also been charged Maria lavova bolova is
seen here loading Ukrainian children on
a bus headed for Russia there are
credible allegations against these
persons for the other crimes Keith
claims more than sixteen thousand
children have been forcefully deported
from occupied areas but they warned that
number could be much higher only 300
have been returned six of them are Olga
lopaken his kids
this is the moment they were reunited
with their mother
every day they turn the children against
us she said adding that Russia told her
children your parents have abandoned you
here you will have a better life Russia
has dismissed the charges as outrageous
and unacceptable and doesn't recognize
the Court's authority meaning a Putin
stays in Russia he won't be arrested but
if he travels to any of the 123 member
countries of the ICC international law
says he must be detained
Mackenzie gray Global News
Ottawa
former U.S president Donald Trump has
taken to social media saying he's
expecting to be arrested this Tuesday
and he's calling on his supporters to
protest New York prosecutors are
considering charging Trump as they
investigate hush money payments made to
women who allege they had sex with him
including former pornography star Stormy
Daniels a trump spokesperson later
clarified prosecutors have not told him
he'll be indicted but that he based his
claims on media reports and what he
described as illegal leaks the Manhattan
district attorney isn't commenting
Trump's successor Joe Biden is now just
days away from his very first visit to
Canada as the American president and
there's no doubt he and prime minister
Justin Trudeau will have plenty to
discuss our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson has a look at what will likely
be on their agenda Mercedes
Faro was a war raging after Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and increasingly
aggressive China and economic
uncertainty around the globe prime
minister Trudeau and President Biden
have their work cut out for them Canada
and the United States are close friends
and allies and while the Biden
presidency has proven more friendly
stable and predictable for Canada U.S
relations there have also been America
First choices that have challenged the
Canadian economy excluded Canada from a
new security pact and put increasing
pressure on the Canadian government to
spend more on defense and security this
week on the west block Canada's
ambassador to the United States Kirsten
Hillman is on the show with an inside
look at what Canada's strategy will be
heading into the presidential visit
one big ask that very well could come
from Joe Biden is for Canada to lead a
mission in Haiti but Canada's top
Soldier General Wayne Air has said the
Canadian military would be hard-pressed
to execute that given the Personnel
shortage Ambassador Hillman hinted that
constant conversations are taking place
and the contribution for Canada may come
from Beyond the military what we're
focusing on is and this is because of
what the Haitian uh the Haitians are
telling us is that what they really need
is for their Police Services to be
properly trained to deal with the
security situation that's where we're
focusing that's what we're talking to
the us about and other partners in the
region who would who would help us in
that so maybe the RCMP is a possibility
there it might be I you know I I'm you
know I'm kind of as ambassador to the
United States I can't speak to the
rcmp's capacity or goodness Grace is
certainly not the uh the military's
capacity there are other people who are
the experts in that but what I can say
is that we are very
um we have we talk to the Americans
all the time after the balloon incidents
the dominated headlines defense and
security especially how much Canada
spends is expected to be a prime topic
for the visit and a potential pressure
point for the Prime Minister Farah
Mercedes thank you looking forward to
your coverage and Mercedes will also
look at whether you should worry about
Canadian Banks after some American and
European financial institutions
collapsed that's on the west block
tomorrow morning right here on global
there are new Ripple effects tonight to
last year's reversal of Roe versus Wade
Wyoming is now the first American state
to ban abortion pills the law takes
effect in July it's part of a larger
Bill aiming to eventually Outlaw all
abortions in Wyoming this week in Texas
a federal judge began reviewing a
lawsuit by an anti-abortion group
seeking to block access to Memphis Stone
a drug first approved in 2000 that
induces medical abortions
a recent drug and weapons bust is
Raising alarm over the role of new
technology in violent crime police in
New Brunswick seized two 3D printed
handguns and the federal Public Safety
Minister says this type of weapon is
part of a growing phenomenon that's
posing challenges for police Callum
Smith explains what may be needed to
combat it
3D printers are an evolving technology
with many beneficial purposes building
things such as Prosthetics shower parts
and other remarkable designs but some
people are taking advantage of them
producing 3D Guns or guns with 3D
components we are clearly at the very
beginning of an upward Trend and it's
one of the alarming trends that we see
within organized crime highlighted by a
recent drug and weapons seizure in New
Brunswick's Capital the city's police
force saying two 3D handguns and a
printer were part of the bust with
charges laid and charges were announced
last month by the Nova Scotia RCMP and
Canada Border Services Agency in a 3D
firearm investigation dating back to
last year they're part of a
classification called ghost guns meaning
they're untraceable because they don't
have serial numbers in Calgary police
reported a jump seizing 16 3D Guns in
2022 still a far cry from the 517
Firearms They seized in all the
challenges that are posed by 3D ghost
guns are significant as you pointed out
this is accessible fast cheap technology
whose main purpose is to evade the long
arm of the law well the printers are
becoming more common it's not so easy to
properly make the components of a 3D
firearm says the founder of a 3D
printing publication when you start
adding up all of the time and trouble
and nonsense you're going to have to go
to to make that like well why don't you
just go in a back alley and buy a metal
gun like it's probably easier to do that
Mount Royal University Professor Doug
King says further technological advances
might be needed for 3D printers similar
to mechanisms preventing people from
using an inkjet printer to produce
counterfeit money because then there's
also the legal side if you think OG it
might be kind of fun to see if I can
make one if you start doing that you've
actually broken the criminal code of
Canada and you could end up in some
really serious problems 3B printers and
ghost guns mean law enforcement is
playing catch-up with quickly evolving
technology G Callum Smith Global News
Halifax
political Fallout Fallout in a Greek
train tragedy coming up why protesters
say it was a disaster waiting to happen
plus rage over France's retirement age
the Constitutional power is causing
clashes on the streets
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
a chaotic scene outside the Islamabad
Courthouse where former Pakistani prime
minister Imran Khan showed up for his
corruption case today his supporters
fought with police and Khan never made
it inside the courtroom prompting the
judge to postpone the hearing to March
30th Khan who served as PM between 2018
and 2022 was accused of unlawfully
selling State gifts given to him by
Foreign dignitaries while in office
oh
and Franz Fury is festering over the
country's deeply unpopular pension
reforms demonstrators marched through
the streets if not today burning trash
while clashing with Wyatt police
protests have also been held in Paris
resulting in days of unrest on Thursday
president Emmanuel Macaulay used special
Constitutional Powers to push through
the controversial Bill raising the
retirement age from 62 to 64. and Greece
is reeling from its worst Royal disaster
in modern history that left nearly 60
people dead outrage has filled the
street since the fiery head-on collision
two and a half weeks ago today the
National Police Chief was fired as the
Prime Minister promises a full and
transparent investigation those words
though are meaningless to the protesters
Crystal commencing Reports on the
intensifying anger there and why people
are blaming the government for the
tragedy
Molotov cocktails and tear gas mix with
shouts of murder and the apology is fake
students rail union workers and average
citizens have been taking to the streets
of Athens in the days since a horrific
head-on collision between two trains
[Music]
only way things will change is if people
come out on the street
the street promises and measures
demonstrators accuse the government of
failing to act on known safety issues
plaguing the nation's rail system issues
that may have led to two trains one full
of passengers the other loaded with
cargo running on the same line for
several kilometers and then colliding
a provisional death toll of 57 was given
at the time many remain unaccounted for
as a result of the speed of the crash
and subsequent explosion DNA testing is
ongoing on remains found at the site and
nearly 50 people are still being treated
in hospital
the European public prosecutor's office
is also now involved it's looking into a
contract about the upgrade of signaling
systems on Greek trains
the Greek Prime Minister toured the site
the day after the crash and has since
offered a lengthy written apology on
Facebook promising to do better his term
is set to end in July but elections
could be pushed back from April until
mid-may
we don't trust any government we believe
only the people will save the people
three rail employees have been charged
in connection with a crash charges range
from causing transport disruption to
manslaughter if convicted the punishment
could be life in prison
as families of the victims Wait For
answers
anger and unrest unfolds on the streets
Crystal gemancing Global News London
[Music]
romance scams at the age of AI ahead the
online business of defrauding the lonely
while kiska's death is tragic her
beautiful soul marks the end of orca
captivity here in Canada
no other Orca will ever have to endure
what she did
a group of animal activists paid tribute
today to kiska the last captive killer
whale in Canada the Orca died at the
Marineland theme park in Niagara Falls a
little more than a week ago kiska was
believed to be 47 years old and was
captured in 1979. she's been in
captivity ever since Maureen lent isn't
commenting on her death
scam artists are now upping the ante as
they prey on lonely people looking for
love they're using artificial
intelligence to create the perfect
person all in an attempt to Rob
vulnerable victims of their money
tomasia Da Silva explains how it works
the Staggering amount of money that's
been lost and how people can avoid being
defrauded
through friends or blind dates I don't
really do the online stuff it is for
desperate people
I'm old-fashioned it appears old is new
again at least with some choosing
in-person courting over computer
chatting never online no no I'm way too
old for that catfishing and whatnot you
gotta keep your eye out for that still
despite the risks online dating remains
popular and very easy especially with
evolving technology like artificial
intelligence a romance scammer's dream
so you start here Matchmaker Crystal
Walter first tells the program what
she's looking for in a date you pick
what type of mail you want ethnicity eye
color hair color the AI program then
does the rest hey Crystal
caress bringing the perfect partner to
life sort of these are all computer
generated so none of these are real
people Walter says they're real enough
to fool many and the numbers prove it
romance scams were the second most
costly scams in Canada last year with
more than 1400 cases reported to the
Canadian anti-fraud Center more than a
thousand actual victims for a loss of 59
million dollars how did it get so far
Walter says as a professional Matchmaker
she vets everyone Googles them checks
their ID and speaks with them something
she advises everyone online dating do
meet them off the app like as fast as
you can he's already gotten 33 likes as
for our perfect partner Chris he's in
high demand but he's not fooling
everyone I have husbands
Global News
[Music]
what can you create with millions of Pop
hand pull tabs next one man's labor of
love
[Music]
how many times have you finished a cat
of pop or beer and tossed it in the
recycling bin and then never gave it a
second thought well an Alberta artist
has done something much different and
he's been doing it for decades a Cris
check reports he's been pulling the tabs
off those cans and creating sculptures
his head is a little garbage pail and
then his arms were the rain rain pipes
it all started almost 30 years ago with
a dream recycled material and pop tabs
if I was younger 30 years I'd build a
museum a recycled Museum 84 year old
Doug fimke started collecting tabs in
the early 90s when he heard they could
be used towards buying wheelchairs for
needy children but was soon discouraged
at how many it would take went to bed
that night you know I don't know if I
was sleeping or if I was still awake but
all of a sudden it was like a vision of
a farm scene in the morning fibke
reimagined the farm vision and said
that's it if I have a million tabs I'll
make a farm scene soon the farm scene
came to life as the tabs just kept
coming in now to this date I got two
million nine hundred and thirty thousand
Tabs Plus a few all put together to make
a barn a horse and fence complete with a
lassu a pig and what farm wouldn't be
complete without a tractor the tractor
Hood comes off and a less traditional
farm machine a spaceship the little guys
they used to build a base a spaceship
you know I know it's got nothing to do
with the farmyard but now we tell the
little guys that say a spaceship that he
had a problem and he had to land
someplace that's what I tell him now
there have been some inquiries from
hotels in Las Vegas even Dollywood about
purchasing the scene it just never quite
lined up properly but now FIB key is
more than ready to sell and pass it on
in more ways than one we'll just keep
enough that we can live on and then the
rest you know we'll go to charity FIB
key hopes his artwork will be
appreciated for years to come and thanks
God for blessing him with such a vision
he gave me the means of getting all the
tabs and he gave me the patience to put
it all together Sierra yes Chuck
Global News
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm far enough sir and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
this wintry shot of Mineville Nova
Scotia we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com until we're
together tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]